hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to neverending nightmares an
intensely interesting and thoroughly
terrifying in the horror game how do I
know this I actually played this game
about a year ago and it first came out
as a demo and everybody say hi to this
little girl if you remember the original
video that I made t get stabbed in the
ad bad stuff happens in this game and I
apologize right off the bat I'm still
very sick I have a double ear infection
and I am hopped up on every cut every
single type of medicine that you could
prop but possibly imagine but I'm a
tough my way through this because this
game is deserving of some
honest-to-goodness good playthrough Ness
and I hope to deliver on that promise
because when I first played this game it
really struck me as interesting because
there's a lot of themes going on the
game that take a lot to notice because
the details of the game are kind of
masked in this art style that you'll see
in front of you it's very monotone it's
very similar line style and basically
the entire game is based on this style
and the world that this guy imagines in
his nightmares and that's really
interesting when you start to think
about how this world actually is in
comparison to everything else that he
understands yeah that's where I wanted
that painting on the ground is much
better than of them
hi hello everybody how are you doing are
you that little girl who got stabbed are
you all judging me because I'm probably
the one that did the stabbing okay
I'm gonna go you say yep you're still
staring at me I'm just gonna leave now
anyway so the mono I can't big word
right now but you know the style of this
game kind of masks something about the
presence it kind of works for it do you
have glasses drawn on your face or those
real I can't even tell hey the way some
artistic douchebag over there doing
something about them but you'll notice
that some things are in color and most
everything is not in color because that
points out what is important and what is
not like this now for a second there I
thought that I can't read that that's
all the original Italian one is there
anything in here that's important for me
to remember because I don't know what's
going on okay anyway I'm gonna move on
now also might I mention the absolute
best place to put a lit candle right by
the books just in case you need some
midnight reading going out of here oh
boy so anyway this game struck me is a
very interesting and unique take on
horror and I always like whenever I see
one of these games and it brings
something new to the table now a sort of
adventure style game
when did the wallpaper become skulls I
don't quite remember putting that up hi
there hello friend how are you doing oh
you're just standing in that wardrobe
are you taking ok I guess I'm not going
to Narnia and what's really interesting
and that I noticed him the last time at
a play this about a year ago I actually
reviewed the video that I played a year
ago just to familiarize myself with it
god I sounded very strange he here ago
and I don't quite remember what is new
and what is old in the game because I I
remember playing through this kind of
beginning area and I saw a lot of the
same things that I saw before ok I was
just turning around because I thought I
missed something
thought I out of the corner of my eye
because I'm trying to look at you guys
either way I'm gonna stop blabbering
here soon enough
you
wait a minute wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
I'm hearing noises and I don't like
hearing the noises okay oh they should
be noted that all blood is very red in
this game you'll notice when there's
blood okay I'm pretty sure I must the
beginning of this game must have been
straight off the demo or it's not I mean
just as an idea to familiarize yourself
that's my shadow there nothing to worry
about I wanted to break that anyway I'm
very angry oh good I don't recognize any
of this okay there yeah that's new in
Super Hill ah go everywhere what is
going on here
I have no goddamn idea again the
wallpaper still skulls not too sure what
that means for me okay this is not what
I wanted I did not want this to turn
into dark wood I don't remember going
outside and there's a butt-hole tree
over there that's usually a bad sign
okay okay okay so we're just going into
the woods of cross-hatching yeah oh
that's a hand that's a tree of hands
don't grab me
okay then expect this to go so weird yet
Oh God for me going into the cemetery of
all places why why not because whenever
someone has a nightmare and was on the
darkness over there huh I see some can't
tell me I don't I see something over
there
all right oh oh it's a beautiful lady oh
good
what hi still sleeping
what promised we need for breakfast ah
oh are you okay ah you look upset I'm
sorry I just had a terrible nightmare
okay Trent you were dead
oh that's silly I'm fine
besides you always promised you take
care of your little I don't think she's
fine when we were kids it's still true
isn't it why don't you try to get back
to sleep no are we supposed to be
getting breakfast wait a minute that's a
bad idea I'm not gonna sleep wait a
minute
Sami right here na na na na there's
still weird whispering in my ears where
are you going lady
there's still a lot of skulls and
vultures going on here
Oh much care for it
I don't think any of that was real okay
yeah there we go
that's good when the blood of all the
Hoos are my teeth aren't they I sure
didn't punch him out of anybody now with
my scrawny noodle arms hey uh beloved
sis you want to come back here and
explain what the hell's going on why
there's so many paintings of meat I hear
that
I hear that okay oh good the best start
to put in your house
a town lynching someone playing town of
Salem hello papa
ma ma bye guys handsome is [ __ ] okay
what is that moaning sounds like me
early this morning when I was first sick
yes who is moaning this early and or
late in the day
as a creepy painting of a lady that's an
ominous staircase there's like some
mixtures of things that are okay there's
a dark hallway over there I can't have
alarm bells going off in my head then I
looked at that and I said no a whole
bunch did I do that
I believe I did that oh this is not much
better well why not
let's go wandering down into the
darkness I'm sure nothing bad will
happen to me I'm sure everything will be
oh why do I keep looking around so much
Oh what no no did I died little goober
go get you sis we're playing hide and
seek for you like 10 feet Oh rough on me
picture the Slenderman over there good
delightful addition to our family of
Horrors and not [ __ ] horrors ones are
gonna I pause it that's that's a thing
that's a whole bunch of things on a door
normal to have in a house I think I
remember that I think I need to go to
the basement to get some sort of a some
sort of a thingy thingy thingy also I
apologize it's still mess in here
I don't I'm not a hundred percent I am
probably not making any sort of sense to
you guys
oh it's the murder block soldiers I
remember you you're all awesome
I also remember from when I played the
witches house a toy soldier shot me in
the face that was fun
oh wait did I say fun I'm an awful
horrible I remember you I remember all
this is my sister's room
remember now she was horribly afflicted
with things too many emotions let me run
away from your fantasy excuse me who's
wait a minute Oh who's crying I have no
idea what's going on with this game but
I know that I love it yeah I really want
to do it justice like I'm not trying to
be silly here to be silly I mean that's
part of my playthrough I know I'm on
cold medicine I do not feel well I still
want to give this game the best
playthrough better wait no no don't do
that
No oh okay good
that happen every hour on the hour
they did good
I'll just go oh it's nice and dark wait
a minute wait a minute I remember
something something chases me here I
remember this I remember this no no no I
remember this no I'm dead serious I
remember this something could happen all
right then
that's how you're gonna be huh so you
gonna be huh yeah that wasn't the thing
I remember the thing it's so weird to
remember a game that I played a year ago
what was that Oh
it's good I love this I love what I get
the tingles when I play a good game
well it's something cool and interesting
finally this is douchebag in the colored
frame
oh he's double fisting wine glasses he's
twice as fancy as the rest of us
screw you ancient picture of Conan
O'Brien I still hear those sounds of
people moaning in the distance did I
mention that I don't like that also
there's kind of mannequins you this is
really that was a close one
okay now there are skull paintings in
the wallpaper wait what's going on whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's pulsating
that was not happening before Conan did
you do that oh yeah this is all so it's
good
okay
why not why not nope nope nope no no no
no nope nope nope nope nope who you
expect me to go in there blind
no [ __ ] yes this candle the red dildo
candle because none other would have
sufficed gotta go let's see what was in
here what nightmare awaits me now oh I
remember my god why have you forsaken me
because you're a douchebag and I'm
obviously better I think question is did
he cut herself open to write the message
or did something else cut himself open
oh I remember
yeah thank you back
Tony's say right there they are
interesting know some sort of refuge
from whatever the hell was over there
good sister okay then here here was when
something chased me you're not gonna get
me this time I'm ready for you
I'm ready for you creepy painting of a
little girl I'm ready for you slender
man in the distance over there I'm ready
for you
crop symbol of Ohio I'm ready for you
screaming baby I'm ready for you
town about to be consumed by weather I'm
ready for you a picture of a soldier I'm
ready for you a picture of crows butt
I wasn't ready for you Bulger okay so
that was all that you and a ding dong
Bing bong again cut off someone's head
no I gotta go through the room of dolls
again this is go again because oh yeah
that's his stuff oh yeah I needed a few
more nightmares I know I'm gonna have
some crazy fever dream you know after
all my medication wears off and I go to
bed I'm gonna my name is not Thomas my
name is Mark my brother's name is Thomas
okay
hello soldiers tinker tinker told your
cellular spy whatever go out of here go
to hell carrying on so now that I got
the equipment ready to go down into the
basement I can get the axe chop those
open and continue on from where I left
off in the first video that I did I
don't remember if the sister ever came
about and told me that I needed to wake
up and go to breakfast I don't remember
that oh good now I can see oh yeah this
place is real nice I do some sprucing up
a bit maybe some scented candles an
Airwick thank you no that's no I
remember this terrible you can carry
both man
[Music]
then time to finish what I started
come here sister of mine for you so the
lights are going out as I go past them
that's a good thing
it's weird even though I've played this
part before like I know what's gonna
happen it's still like my heart's racing
and I love it that's what I love about
playing these really good interesting
games but they still get you because of
the world also I got the volume like
blast it out in my ears that kind of
helps it's not as dark as I would like
because I haven't know I'm out of here
there's always a lot longer than I
remember it to be that's a nice chair
maybe a shut up shut up [ __ ] no don't
you need to keep moving there
thank you stop being such a big wimp and
chop down those boards
uh-huh okay carrying on yep there's the
moaning again oh good ol moaning man I
gotta say those lights do not do
anything for me okay sorry
no no this bad no this is bad no no
don't look at me okay okay we've
officially reached the part of the game
that we have not yet played this is
where the game officially starts to get
interesting but unfortunately I have to
end the episode here but I will pick
this right back up as soon as I can so
thank you all so much for watching check
out the other playthroughs that I've
done of various interesting horror games
in the description below or through the
annotations tell me what you think of
this game I really want to know what you
think of this game because to me the
simplicity of it and there's a lot more
complexity to it than is on the surface
but the simplicity of the art style
really adds to focus the experience on
just the horror and it makes the weird
things stand out as even weirder if you
know what I'm talking about if anything
but either way let me know in the
comments below I am going to play a few
more episodes until my cold medicine
wears off I'm gonna collapse in the bed
and become a frothing lunatic on the
phone but either way thank you again
everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh
[Music]
sorry there's anything that happened
before I don't remember
[Music]